also herzlich willkommen bei The Voice
der Talk und das ist immer mit einem
einzigen das Michael Schulte bei kriegst
und warum weil er ist der einzige
Youtuber der so weit und überhaupt
geschafft hat bei The Voice vor allen
Dingen am letzten Freitag als der Notar
kam ich konnte es kaum glauben er sagt
ja mit deutlichen Vorsprung was hast du
in der Sekunde gedacht ich habe das so
ehrlich gesagt gar nicht richtig
mitgekriegt was er gesagt hat ich habe
da gar nicht hingehört ich war so
aufgeregt und habe eigentlich fest damit
gerechnet dass Personal da jetzt
weiterkommt weil er immer weiter
gekommen ist ich meine das ist ja war ja
der große Favorit irgendwie bei The
Voice und ich habe echt nicht damit
gerechnet und als dann der Stefan gerade
gesagt hat Michael Schulte ich glaube
man hat auch gesehen ich bin da ganz
schön ausgerastet und ich glaube ich auf
dem Boden geschmissen und da drauf
geklopft und bin auf der Bühne total
sind wahrscheinlich rum gesprungen aber
ich habe mich richtig gefreut und
das war der Hammer auf jeden Fall genau
so und jetzt vielleicht waren wir
Youtuber das Zünglein an der Waage weil
wir haben versucht ordentlich was zu
reißen für dich und ich habe fast den
Eindruck wir haben es geschafft und das
müssen wir natürlich jetzt wiederholen
aber da müssen wir noch einen Scheiß
drauflegen weil jetzt es wird ja immer
enger es gibt immer weniger Nummern für
die angerufen werden kann das heißt es
müssen immer mehr Leute anrufen und
jetzt eben für Michael das heißt die die
das was wir jetzt tun müssen ist alle
zum Telefonhörer greifen oder eine SMS
schicken zu der Michael Schulte
Rufnummer wird in der Show eingeblendet
weil beim letzten mal war nur 20 Minuten
in dem immer anrufen konnte es ging
wirklich da um die Wurst da musste man
richtig Gas geben und wir haben es
geschafft und jetzt müssen natürlich
schauen dass wir uns nicht zu sicher
fühlen ich meine jetzt irgendwie denken
vielleicht alle ey der hat so viele
Anrufe gekriegt sogar mehr als Person
will der kommt so oder so ins Finale da
muss man jetzt glaube ich aufpassen und
bloß nicht nachlassen also fleißig
anrufen das wäre super und dann schaffen
wir es vielleicht sogar ins Finale gut
es gab jetzt manche Kommentare haben
gesagt ja doof da irgendwie nur für den
Michael Schulze nein es geht natürlich
auch darum den besten zu wählen und
Michael Schulte würde ich jetzt mal
sagen gehört zum Besten und das wirst du
dieses Mal mit einem Song beweisen
welcher ist es ganz ist schon sagen dass
du nicht sagen oder gar nicht ausgesucht
ich darf noch nicht verraten nee
das wird ja immer ein paar Tage vorher
damit gegeben aber heute ist noch nicht
ein paar Tage vorher okay also wir
machen das nämlich diesmal möglichst
lange vorher damit sich möglichst viele
Leute dieses Video angucken möglichst
viele anrufen aber du hast ja das ein
oder andere Experiment gemacht die Zeit
sind wahrscheinlich vorbei
das kann man nie so genau sagen können
schon sein dass ich da auf einmal
irgendwie mit so einem gotele jetzt
auftauche
alles passieren okay wir lassen uns
überraschen also für den Anrufen
natürlich nur wenn er ihn auch gut
findet aber ich hoffe ihr findet ihn gut
und das heißt wie immer bei uns am Ende
des Videos machen also Busche und dann
heißt es diesmal voten Noten